this morning we have a breakthrough in a
murder case that got national attention
police say they have made an arrest in
the killings of 13-year-old Abigail
Williams and 14 year old Liberty German
in Delphi Indiana more than five years
ago the suspect is 50 years old his name
is Richard Allen he was taken into
custody last week he is charged with two
counts of murder and he has pleaded not
guilty Charlie Demar reports on the long
search that led police to this suspect
this investigation is far from complete
the arrest of Richard Allen may just be
the beginning authorities say the murder
suspect is in jail without bond but a
tip line related to the 2017 killing of
Abby Williams and Libby German will
remain open prosecutor when did Richard
Allen become a suspect that's part of
the investigation so I'm not going to
talk about those things police say they
took Allen into custody on Friday more
than five years after the eighth grade
girls disappeared while hiking near
Delphi their bodies were found one day
later on Valentine's Day at the time law
enforcement released this video and
audio of a suspect
which they extracted from Libby German's
phone our lives for five and a half
years have been in a search Becky Patty
is German's grandmother and said the
suspect's arrest raises a new question
what do victims families do now police
and locals say Allen was an unassuming
member of the Delphi Community he worked
at the local CVS where Patty said he
wants processed photos for the family
and never charged them it's always not
settled well with me the fact that
whoever is responsible for this
has been walking around now for five and
a half years as a free person Mike Patty
is German's grandfather nothing's ever
going to bring Liberty back that's just
a fact will we ever be done grieving
morning no for CBS mornings Charlie
Demar Delphi Indiana